und jetzt das heute journal
[Musik]
guten abend diplomatie bringt keine
ergebnisse ich habe keine leben mehr zu
verschenken
das sagte der ukrainische präsident des
elends die kürzlich in einem interview
mit dem us-sender cbs dass die
ukrainische regierung auf diplomatische
gepflogenheiten keine großen rücksichten
mehr nimmt hat dann heute der deutsche
bundespräsident erfahren einmal mehr
muss man sagen frank walter steinmeier
war zuletzt schon vom ukrainischen
botschafter in berlin attackiert worden
doch heute ging hier weit darüber hinaus
steinmeier war zu besuch in polen und
wollte von dort zusammen mit dem
polnischen und den drei baltischen
präsidenten nach kiew reisen die lenski
ist jedoch wissen er sei dort nicht
willkommen
mein kollege und freund der polnische
staatspräsident asi hat in den
vergangenen tagen angeregt dass wir
beide gemeinsam mit den präsidenten
estland lettland und litauen eine reise
nach kiew unternehmen um dort ein
starkes zeichen gemeinsame europäische
solidarität mit der ukraine zu senden
und zu setzen ich war dazu bereit
aber offenbar und ich muss zur kenntnis
nehmen wahr dass in kiew nicht gewünscht
theo koll das ist ja doch ein fachlich
massiver diplomatischer affront gegen
ein staatsoberhaupt und gegen steinmeier
persönlich oder
absolut also ein zweifaches jahr auf die
frage die abweisung gilt einerseits der
person steinmeiers aber ist ja gar nicht
zu trennen von dessen amt als
staatsoberhaupt die person steinmeier
ist für die ukrainische politik vor
allem jahr der langjährige deutsche
außenminister dem zu enge beziehungen zu
russland vorgeworfen werden und der vor
kurzem selbst auch fehler in seiner
russlandpolitik zugegeben hat der
ukrainische botschafter hat die kritik
hier sehr offen formuliert steinmeier
habe ein spinnennetz der kontakte mit
russland geknüpft und das verhältnis zu
russland sagte botschafter sei für
steinmeier etwas heiliges gewesen diese
kritik aber und steinmeier wissen zu
lassen dass er in kiew ein unerwünschter
gast
das ist natürlich gleichzeitig auch
einer frauen gegen das deutsche
staatsoberhaupt und damit eigentlich
gegen die bundesrepublik insgesamt der
polnische präsident du da jedenfalls hat
so höre ich heute die hände über dem
kopf zusammengeschlagen als er von der
ausladung steinmeiers hörte und meinte
das helfe doch am ende nur putin gibt es
dann reaktionen darauf in berlin
ja also berlin reagiert offiziell betont
cool ein regierungssprecher hat nur
knapp schriftlich erklärt deutschland
gehöre zu den entschiedensten
unterstützer und der ukraine und auch
der bundespräsident beziehe ja klar und
eindeutig stellung auf seiten der
ukraine der spd fraktionschef rolf
mützenich hat heute abend daran erinnert
dass deutschland die ukraine seit vielen
jahren wirtschaftlich und ja seit
kriegsbeginn auch humanitär und
militärisch unterstützt mein eindruck
ist dass kiew sich mit dieser aktion
politisch und auch emotional keinen
gefallen getan hat auch der dauer
kritische und fordernde ton des
ukrainischen botschaft das wird hier in
berlin zwar einerseits verstanden aber
um ehrlich zu sein auch zunehmend
genervt entgegengenommen so hatte er
sich am wochenende schon eher eine kiew
reise des kanzlers gewünscht die von
steinmeier sagte er habe nur
symbolischen charakter die einladungen
scholz hat er heute abend übrigens
erneuert aber um ehrlich zu sein mit
einer abweisung des bundespräsidenten
von heute dürfte eine kanzler reise
absehbar unwahrscheinlich werden das
gebietet auch schon der respekt vor dem
vierten staatsoberhaupt danke theo für
die einschätzung andere europäische und
auch deutsche politiker hingegen reisen
in die ukraine und sind dort auch
gekommen so fuhren heute drei prominente
vertreter des deutschen bundestags in
den westen des landes die vorsitzenden
der parlamentsausschüsse für
verteidigung auswärtiges und europa
marie agnes strack zimmermann michael
roth und anton hofreiter ein dass sie
alle drei auf mehr tempo bei
waffenlieferungen kochen und damit nicht
immer in einklang mit dem
bundeskanzleramt stehen andreas künast
hat sie auf dieser reise begleiten
für diesen einsatz gehört blaulicht aufs
dach gehören splitterschutzwesten in den
kofferraum gehört schwarz-rot-gold
hinter die gepanzerte frontscheibe in
der polnischen grenzstadt geschafft hat
ein dutzend sicherheitsbeamter eine
reise vorbereitet von der sie eigentlich
abraten aber die abgeordneten hofreiter
brot und strack zimmermann haben sich
die genehmigungen erkämpft dieses
zeichen muss sein und es muss jetzt sein
die reise war selbstverständlich nicht
einfach zu organisieren
denn es ist ein kriegsgebiet auch wenn
wir nur im westen der ukraine unterwegs
sind und es ist einfach zentral um
solidarität zu zeigen und um sich ein
bild vor ort zu machen für ein chef an
die grenze vom frieden in den krieg
braucht der deutsche konvoi eine
dreiviertelstunde deutschland ist spät
dran bei besuchen aber auch bei anderen
entscheidungen über sanktionen über
waffenlieferungen
am stau an der grenze darf die kolonne
vorbei einer der vorteile wenn man gast
des landes ist diplomatenpass anmeldung
willkommen in der ukraine
man muss auch ein paar signale setzen
dass man versucht auch anteil zu nehmen
und diese gesten der solidarität die
sollte man nicht unterschätzen aber noch
einmal das hat mich zu entscheiden und
zu bewerten das haben unsere
ukrainischen partnerinnen und partner zu
entscheiden dass genau in diesen minuten
die ukrainischen partner entscheiden
dass sie vom bundespräsidenten kein
signal der solidarität wollen werden die
bundestags reisenden zunächst gar nicht
glauben
aber in lemberg am sitz der
regionalregierung bekommen auch sie zu
spüren wie enttäuscht die ukraine von
deutschland ist kommen sie erst mal rein
hier ist es sicher
beim treffen mit abgeordneten der
werkhof nada des kieler parlaments liegt
nach wenigen minuten eine liste auf dem
tisch marder ausführung 1 mit
typenbezeichnung und foto die
parlamentskollegen aus der ukraine
argumentieren kenntnisreich aber auch
emotional
ich bitte sie von ganzem herzen nutzen
sie ihren einfluss danke
in ihren parteien gelten die drei
ausschussvorsitzenden als besonders
entschiedene unterstützer der ukraine
vor zwei tagen hat strack-zimmermann
ihre meinung geändert von gegen auf für
die lieferung schwerer waffen dass sie
an dem tag eingeladen sind an dem ihr
staatsoberhaupt ausgeladen wird muss
erst noch verarbeitet werden ja das ist
ein ungewöhnlicher vorgang und das
sollte man glaube ich in ruhe klären was
dahinter steckt das ist nicht freundlich
aber ich glaube dass die nerven überall
blank liegen und deswegen empfehle ich
in diesem fall hinter den kulissen mal
zu klären es muss noch einiges geklärt
werden diplomatisch militärisch
emotional hinter den kulissen und davor
wir brauchen waffen keine warmen worte
so sieht es die ukrainische regierung
schwere waffen sollen geliefert werden
möglichst viel möglichst schnell zumal
damit gerechnet wird dass die russen in
den nächsten tagen einen großangriff im
osten starten und ihnen im süden die
hafenstadt maria poll endgültig in die
hände zu fallen droht was kann der
westen was kann deutschland liefern dazu
gleich fragen an ex nato general ramms
vorab wirft uwe kröger einen kurzen
blick auf die waffen über die
hierzulande diskutiert wird sie beginnt
ihren bericht aber mit dem neuesten
auftritt von putin
für wladimir putin ist es eine ideale
kulisse und ein perfekter zeitpunkt
zusammen mit den belarussischen
präsidenten lukaschenko besucht er heute
an der chinesischen grenze das kosmodrom
vor genau 61 jahren flug der russische
kosmonaut gagarin als erster mensch ins
weltall von hier lässt putin die welt
wissen er wird gewinnen
wir werden unsere ziele erreichen
derweil sammelt die russische armee
weiter kräfte für ihren grossangriff im
osten der ukraine
die ukrainische regierung fleht die welt
weiter an zu helfen mit waffen und einem
embargo
was mich am meisten besorgt ist dass die
entscheidungsprozesse in berlin so lange
dauern wer in berlin zeit hatte es nicht
was kiew will sind artillerie
raketenabwehrsysteme und panzer zum
beispiel den leopard oder martha
die firma rheinmetall ließ wissen man
könne den leopard 1 innerhalb von sechs
wochen liefern
während die aussenministerin auf eine
schnelle lieferung drin bleibt es im
kanzleramt still auch die
verteidigungsministerin eher defensiv
erklärungsversuche ich bitte auch
nachzuvollziehen dass wir in bezug auf
die ankündigung von dem was wir liefern
von dem was wir leisten dass wir da sehr
sehr verschwiegen damit umgehen dass die
ukraine mit deutschen waffen und panzer
nicht umgehen könne wurde von kiew
bereits mehrfach zurückgewiesen
wir wissen genau wie wir mit den waffen
und geräten umgehen müssen mit allen ob
mit flugabwehrraketen oder panzern das
ist kein geheimnis für uns
wir sind seit acht jahren darin geübt
weil wir an nato übungen teilgenommen
haben
[Musik]
in mario pohl im süden der ukraine gibt
die offensive russischer truppen weiter
mehr als 10.000 tote soll es dort geben
eine geburtsklinik wurde evakuiert hier
in diesem bunker gibt es babys die noch
nie das tageslicht gesehen haben
experten sprechen mit egon ramms general
ade des heeres der bundeswehr und herr
rams war eine der höchsten nato generäle
und nahm general ramms
großonkel die ukraine sagen wir brauchen
jetzt nicht nur defensivwaffen wir
brauchen jetzt waffen mit denen wir auch
angreifen und gebiete zurückerobern
können schweres gerät
hier habe ich das als laie zu verstehen
salopp gesagt mit panzerfäusten kann man
einen krieg nicht gewinnen
mit panzerfäusten könne man das
erreichen was die ukrainische
streitkräfte in den letzten wochen
erreicht haben nämlich die russen
aufzuhalten und da wo die russen
vorgedrungen sind oder auch die
separatisten wie beispielsweise in mario
pohl können sie diese bereiche mit
panzerfäusten oder infanteriewaffen kaum
zurück erobern und die ukraine muss ein
interesse daran haben beispielsweise
mario mario pohl zu entsetzen bei auch
andere bereiche die erobert worden sind
auch im bereich der separatisten gebiete
wieder zurück zu bekommen und daher ist
die forderung nach schweren waffen
durchaus nachvollziehbar schwere waffen
das meint vor allem auch panzer und da
haben wir eben im bericht auch gesehen
da werden auch konkrete forderungen auf
den tisch gelegt und es gibt angebote
von der deutschen rüstungsindustrie und
heißt es immer von bundeswehr seiten
also nicht von allen aber von so einigen
aus dem verteidigungsministerium das
geht gar nicht die ukraine müssen wir
erstmal lernen mit umzugehen die man so
ein marder oder ein leopard 1 eines
dieser ausgemusterten panzer fährt der
bus der ukrainische
verteidigungsminister sagt dass es
nützlich natürlich können wir das wie
schätzen sie das sein
es ist bedarf sicherlich eine ausbildung
sowohl am leopard 1 auf 5 also vom
schützenpanzer marder
möglicherweise auch artillerie waschen
die damit zu gehören könnten also
panzerhaubitzen raketenwerfer und
dergleichen die auch nach meinem
kenntnisstand mit auf der wunschliste
der ukraine stehen die frage ist wie
weit sich diese ausbildung aus denen
muss die ukraine haben sich in den
letzten wochen unter beweis gestellt
dass sie relativ schnell mit neuen gerät
umgehen können auch wenn dieses schulter
gestützte waffen panzerfäuste und
flieger fäuste waren so glaube ich
trotzdem dass sie sich in die bedienung
solcher waffen sehr schnell rein
arbeiten würden und wenn man sich dabei
entsprechend unterstützt kann man auch
erreichen dass sie auf einer kürzung
zeitachse als sie im augenblick in
deutschland diskutiert wird mit den
waffen entsprechend umgehen können ein
anderes argument ist die bundeswehr kann
jetzt gar keine marder die sie aktuell
benutzt abgeben dann müsste sie die aus
litauen zurückziehen und dann könnte sie
ihren nato verpflichtungen nicht mehr
nachkommen etwas vereinfacht gesagt
darstellen die bundeswehr irgendwann
blank da dass das ginge auch nicht steht
so schlimm um unser heer so sie wissen
ja
wissen ja von der aussage des
inspekteurs des heeres den erläutert
wenn sich die bündnisverpflichtungen
hinaus geht dann stehen wir blank da es
handelt sich hierbei sowohl bei den
leopard 15 als auch bei den morden um
waffen die in der truppe nicht mehr im
gebrauch sind weil sie beispielsweise
durch den zulaufenden schützenpanzer
puma ersetzt werden und wenn die
industrie solche waffen auf dem hof
stehen hat dann sollte man sich mit der
industrie zusammensetzt und sollte
kreative lösungen finden um auf diese
art und weise die ukraine zu
unterstützen vor slomka ich bin der
meinung die ukraine verteidigt die
europäische und auch die deutsche
freiheit in der ukraine von der als jede
unterstützung verdient da gibt es ja
auch durchaus generelle ex generäle die
da anderer meinung sind also zum
beispiel früheren militärberater von
frau merkel ihre fahrt brigadegeneral
sagten schwere waffen in die ukraine
liefern das ist sehr sehr riskant das
könnte den weg zu noch schlimmeren
eskalationen oder gar dritten weltkrieg
ebnen
also den dritten weltkrieg sehe ich
nicht eskalation sind natürlich möglich
weil keiner von uns sagen kann wie der
präsident putin auf diese dinge
reagieren wird aber wir wissen auch dass
aus der tschechei aus der tschechischen
republik
schützenpanzer und kampfpanzer geliefert
worden sind und dieses bisher ohne
reaktion geblieben von daher wir müssen
wir sehen wie wir der ukraine auf der
einen seite helfen können ohne die
eskalation schwelle zu einer direkten
auseinandersetzung zwischen nato und
mustern zu überschreiten wir haben noch
eine kleine kurze frage zum schluss
putin hat ja offenbar seinen
oberbefehlshaber also sein top general
für den krieg in der ukraine
ausgetauscht man sie waren selbst
general ist das normal dass man mitten
im krieg die pferde wechselt auf dieser
ebene
also normalerweise bevor man einen krieg
beginnt hat man die generelle in die
entsprechenden positionen gesetzt zu
denen man entsprechend vertrauen hat wir
müssen aber jetzt sicherlich bilanzieren
wie der angriff bisher auf die ukraine
verlaufen ist und wenn wir den angriff
auf kiew sehen muss man ganz klar sagen
dieser ist gescheitert was ja auch zu
einer umgruppierung geführt hat und
daraufhin hat putin möglicherweise für
den oberbefehlshaber diese operation das
vertrauen verloren interessanter
einschätzung eines hacks generals hermes
vielen dank für das gespräch
herzlichen dank
derweil kommen aus der ukraine immer
mehr berichte über gräueltaten der
russischen armee oder ihrer söldner in
gebieten aus denen sie wieder abgezogen
sind berichten frauen über
vergewaltigungen und erschießungen es
werden folteropfer massengräber und
leichen gefunden
und es werden beweise gesammelt
dazu passt dieses riesige plakat das am
rathaus der litauischen hauptstadt
vilnius packt eine botschaft an den
russischen präsidenten putin den haag
wartet auf dich den haag sitz des
internationalen
strafgerichtshofs tim kröger war heute
für uns in butter jener inzwischen auf
so furchtbare weise berühmt gewordenen
stadt im großraum kiew
aufräumen in butter ob mit schwerem
gerät oder dem besen den menschen kann
es nicht schnell genug gehen die äußeren
zeichen der russischen angriffe der
besatzung zu beseitigen innerlich aber
bleiben die wunden valentina weil sie
lieber hat alles miterlebt die angriffe
die toten auf der straße sie nennt uns
namen zeigt wo die menschen erschossen
lagen und beerdigt wurden
ich weine die ganze zeit ich weine nur
das ist alles weinen was soll ich nur
fühlen nach all dem es war doch so schön
hier
ob die wunden irgendwann heilen wird
auch von der aufarbeitung der
gräueltaten abhängen mord folter
vergewaltigung bomben auf zivilisten die
ermittlungen laufen bereits massengräber
werden geöffnet hunderte todesopfer aus
dem großraum kiel obduziert
jede leiche die bereits identifiziert
ist wird forensisch untersuchen wie jene
die noch nicht identifiziert sind werden
wir dna tests durchführen um
herauszufinden wer sie sind dann werden
wie die todesursache
feststellen weilburg und jeden tag
werden weitere leichen entdeckt
pressetermin mit der ukrainischen
generalstaatsanwälten heute in butter es
geht um tausende fälle mutmaßlicher
kriegsverbrechen mit hunderten
verdächtigen auf seiten des russischen
militärs und der russischen führung
wir sollten unsere fälle so aufbereiten
dass die ankläger der internationalen
gerichte unsere felle aufnehmen und
unsere beweise nutzen können nach den
standards internationalen humanitären
rechts
internationaler ermittler helfen bei den
untersuchungen seit heute im einsatz in
der ukraine französische
ermittlungsbeamte
auch internationale
menschenrechtsorganisationen wie human
rights watch sichern beweise führen etwa
zeugen interviews durch es ist ein
rennen gegen die zeit
im moment kommen die entgegen den die
vor einigen tagen zurück erobert wurden
als die russischen kräfte abgezogen sind
und in solchen gebieten gibt es
potenziell viele wertvolle beweise für
mögliche verbrechen aber diese
verschwinden mit jeder minute die
vergeht
ob allerdings die mutmaßlichen täter
jemals vor gericht stehen und für die
kriegsverbrechen in der ukraine zur
rechenschaft gezogen werden können ist
völlig unklar
und jetzt erstmal andere nachrichten des
tages von hans wolff außenministerin
berbalk ist seit heute in mali wo im
rahmen von internationalen missionen
auch die bundeswehr im einsatz ist die
aktuellen bundestagsmandat für die
deutsche beteiligung laufen ende mai aus
beim besuch des bundeswehr-kontingents
ingo wollte sich berbalk vor ort ein
bild machen über einen einsatz unter
schwierigen rahmenbedingungen an der un
mission zur stabilisierung des von
islamistischem terrorismus bedrohten
landes sind derzeit rund 1000 deutsche
soldaten beteiligt
nach dem rücktritt von
bundesfamilienministerin spiegel haben
sich die grünen auf ihrer
vorstandsklausur in schleswig holstein
noch nicht auf eine nachfolgerin
festgelegt feststehen soll nach worten
von co-chefin ricarda lang bisher nur
dass wieder eine frau das amt übernehmen
soll der vorstand der partei wolle
zeitnah einen entsprechenden vorschlag
machen
in der sogenannten party gate affäre
verhängt die londoner polizei ein
strafgeld gegen den britischen
premierminister johnson es geht offenbar
um die feier in johnsons büro zu seinem
geburtstag am 19 juni 2020 johnson
erklärte er habe das strafgeld bezahlt
und bat um entschuldigung
in new york im stadtteil brooklyn hat
ein unbekannter in der u-bahn zehn
menschen durch schüsse verletzt nach
bisherigen ermittlungen hat der mann in
einer u-bahn die in eine station einfuhr
eine gasmaske aufgesetzt und einem
behälter geöffnet außerdem brauchen den
waggon strömte dann schoss er und
verletzte menschen im zug und auf dem
bahnsteig der täter ist auf der flucht
die hintergründe sind unklar
wir kommen noch mal zurück zum thema
krieg in der ukraine und den folgen für
deutschland welche auswirkungen ein
vollständiges energie in baku gegen
russland auf die deutsche wirtschaft
haben würde ist ja unter ökonomen
umstritten
einigkeit herrscht aber darüber dass wir
uns so schnell wie möglich vom
russischen erdgas unabhängig machen
müssen und das dauerhaft auf dem weg
dahin werde aber manche kröte zu
schlucken sein warnen fachleute ideale
lösungen mit denen auch umweltschützer
glücklich sind werde es kurzfristig
nicht geben elisabeth schmidt berichtet
wie sich wieder sachsen jetzt auf die
errichtung von flüssiggasterminals
einrichten so sieht er aus der
niedersächsische gas turbo ein karton
mit 7000 seiten die
genehmigungsunterlagen für das
flüssigerdgas terminal in stade sie sind
eingereicht keiner der anderen geplanten
lng standorte ist bislang so weit
gekommen gerne von neuer deutschland
geschwindigkeit warum weil wir auch den
druck haben ich finde es erschreckend
dass es sozusagen so weit kommen musste
dass dieser krieg in der ukraine und die
die unabhängigkeit die wir herstellen
wollen dazu führt dass wir schneller
werden beim ausbau der infrastruktur der
politische wille gewinn und so sollen
tanker hier bereits 2024 zwei jahre
früher als bislang geplant flüssiggas an
land bringen in der aktuellen energie
krise kommt das terminal in stade
dennoch zu spät jetzt rächt sich dass
deutschland anders als seine
europäischen nachbarn bislang vollauf
russisches pipeline gas gesetzt hat wenn
sie abhängig sind von pipelines dann
können haben sie in der in einer
politischen krise keine alternative
möglichkeit schnell flüssiggas zu
importieren
wenn sie aber ein flüssiggasterminal
haben und es gibt probleme in einem
lieferland dann können sie den tanker
irgendwo in ein anderes land schicken
bis lng terminals in deutschland
errichtet sind könnten diese
spezialschiffe eine übergangslösung sein
sie wandeln flüssiges lng wieder in gas
um sind mobil und mietbar eines davon
soll bereits zum jahreswechsel in
wilhelmshaven fest machen und ein
fünftel des russischen gases ersetzen
was bislang fehlt eine 28 kilometer
lange gasleitung die lng anleger und
gasspeicher verbindet eine firma bekommt
nun acht monate zeit fairen baum unser
eigentümer haben letzte woche die finale
investitionsentscheidung getroffen so
dass wir bereits jetzt in dieser phase
wo wir noch keine genehmigungen haben
euro bestellt haben
engagieren planen im turbotempo ohne
genehmigung es ist dass tesla prinzip
doch ärger scheint auch in wilhelmshaven
programmiert denn die gasleitung soll
durch wohn und naturschutzgebiete führen
diese flüssig kostüme sind unter
störfall betrieb das sind gefährliche
betriebe die müssen ordentlich genehmigt
werden uns da kann man nicht einfach die
umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung
überspringen ob und wie viele klagen
kommen werden unklar viel
überzeugungsarbeit wird nötig sein und
viel steuergeld 200 millionen euro sind
für die terminals stade und
wilhelmshaven eingeplant 250 millionen
für brunsbüttel wir müssen uns einfach
vergegenwärtigen dass
versorgungssicherheit auch immer etwas
kostet es ist ein öffentliches gut und
kann aus meiner sicht oder konnte aus
meiner sicht auch niemals alleine der
industrie oder den globalen märkten
überlassen werden gas statt grünes
gewissen der krieg in der ukraine zwingt
deutschland zum handeln langfristig soll
sich aber auch das terminal in stade in
richtung mehr klimaschutz bewegen statt
fossilem lng soll dann grüner
wasserstoff importiert werden
krieg und hohe energiepreise tragen
natürlich auch zur inflation bei und mit
dem thema geht es jetzt bereits weiter
da die inflation hat deutlich angezogen
die usa und deutschland melden heute für
märz inflationsraten so hoch wie seit
jahrzehnten nicht 7,3 prozent betrug sie
hierzulande im jahresvergleich laut
statistischem bundesamt stefanie bareth
in welchen bereichen sind die preise
besonders stark gestiegen verbraucher
müssen tatsächlich für fast alles tiefer
in die tasche greifen ob beim tanken
heizen oder im supermarkt spitzenreiter
nach wie vor die energiekosten sie
bleiben angeheizt durch den ukraine
krieg preistreiber nummer eins so ist
heizöl inzwischen mehr als doppelt so
teuer wie im vorjahr dieselkraftstoff
liegt um über 60 prozent zu und gas
verteuert sich um 42 die stromkosten
steigen um 18 prozent auch für
lebensmittel müssen verbraucher mehr
ausgeben speisefette durch den ukraine
krieg knapper verteuerten sich um 17
prozent frisches gemüse umfasst 15
butter um 18 und tiefkühlobst um gut 22
prozent
dabei scheint das ende der preisspirale
noch nicht erreicht denn auch deutsche
großhändler meldeten heute
rekordverdächtige preiserhöhungen von 23
prozent weil rohstoffe und vorprodukte
knapper sind der großhandel gilt ja so
als scharnier zwischen herstellern und
endkunden höhere kosten landen gern
verzögert bei verbrauchern immer weiter
entfernt sich damit die inflationsrate
vom zielkorridor 2 prozent den die
europäische zentralbank als ideal für
preisstabilität und konjunktur ansieht
in den usa hat die inflation heute die
marke von acht prozent geknackt dort
steuert die us notenbank aber längst mit
entschiedenen zinsschritten dagegen der
druck auf die ezb am donnerstag ein
signal auszusenden erwächst stefanie
bareth vielen dank
die dfb-frauen haben die vorzeitige
qualifikation für die wm 2003 und 20
verpasst das deutsche frauen
nationalteam verlor 2 zu 3 gegen die
mannschaft serbiens dennoch bleibt
deutschland in der gruppe im moment auf
platz eins
der schauspieler und schriftsteller
michael degen ist tot er starb nach
angaben des rowohlt verlags am samstag
im alter von 90 jahren in hamburg sie
ist in der realität so kannten ihn
millionen doktor martin sanders in diese
drombuschs eine seiner bekanntesten und
zugleich seine paraderolle graumelierter
gentleman attraktiv publikumsliebling
seine eigene leidenschaft gilt erst dem
theater faust hamlet rund 40 jahre
spielt michael degen die großen helden
ab mitte der 80er traumschiff und
kollegen geht in serie und wendet sich
der tv kamera zu
ein leichtes spiel hier schwer war das
wirkliche leben des gebürtigen
chemnitzers michaels jüdische familie
wird von den nazis verfolgt der vater im
kz ermordet seine mutter und er
überleben in einem versteck niemals
darüber reden das musste er seiner
mutter versprechen sagte jetzt wollen
wir ganz normale menschen sein und
das ist wirklich nötig dass man
verdrängt glaubt mir ich glaube es war
nicht richtig heute mit 67 bricht er das
schweigen schreibt biographien und setzt
sich auch als schauspieler mit der shoah
auseinander für seine rolle als
holocaust überlebender in soko leipzig
bekommt er einen fernsehpreis
von einer familie geblieben ist
michael degen ein leben für das
schauspiel und für die erinnerung
das was für uns an diesem dienstagabend
gleich folgt das neue zdf format don't
stop the music an einer berliner
grundschule begleitete bülent ceylan 50
kinder die erstmals die magie des
musizierens erleben gibt sehr ans herz
und ist zugleich ein wissenschaftliches
projekt große ein schaltempfehlung oder
0 15 gibt es dann unser heute schnell
update mit gundula gause und uns morgen
wieder auf wiedersehen wiedersehen
[Musik]
schon gut ab und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter der märz war nicht nur in
deutschland zu trocken sondern in teilen
europas in rot dargestellt sind die
gebiete wo es 20 prozent und weniger
regen gehabt im gesamten monat es war
durchaus richtung polen der fall und
auch richtung skandinavien generell in
europa war es viel zu trocken wie man
hier an den farben erkennen kann ja
eigentlich im südwesten europas richtung
spanien war es sogar zu nass da war die
meiste zeit tiefer luftdruck ansonsten
die meiste zeit bei uns aber hoher
luftdruck wir schauen auf das aktuelle
wetter und da haben wir es zwar noch mit
hohem luftdruck zu tun das wird aber
gestört von diesem tief über den
britischen inseln und dieses tief wird
uns erreichen morgen am nachmittag wird
schauer und gewitter auslösen dabei
kommt auch warme luft und saharastaub
mez in der nacht gibt es wenige wolken
im osten deutschlands sonst sind
schleierwolken unterwegs saharastaub
kann schon dabei sein und temperaturen
sinken auf null gerade im osten und 10
grad ganz im westen es ist eine deutlich
mildere nacht als sie nachts zuvor
morgan tagesverlauf viel sonnenschein
aber zum nachmittag dann schauer und
gewitter die vor allem dann richtung
nordosten ziehen sonst kann es eben auch
wieder saharastaub geben und der trübt
ein wenig den himmel temperaturen
erreichen 15 bis 16 grad an der nordsee
sonst werte um die 20 grad marke 24 grad
im rhein-main-gebiet und am oberrhein
die nächsten tage am donnerstag schauer
und gewitter die durchziehen bei 12 bis
22 grad oder ab karfreitag ist es im
norden kühler ein senat